so uh Alex Jones so you let's say uh you
have a crystal ball Alex before you
started this Crusade and who you are
right now to this day and you could see
everything that they've done and where
you're at right now do you change
anything do you do anything different
not to get to because you saw what's
what they did what they're doing to you
you know hindsight's 2020 and I see how
God works How the Universe Works the
Lord Works mysterious ways yeah I would
have done a lot of things different
I didn't realize how influential I was
even 15 years ago and I would just be
doing five six hours a day some days and
just having fun sometimes I do nighttime
shows have a few martinis and you know
say stuff tongue-in-cheek and and then
that let them spin it and do things and
then take it out of context uh but that
probably added to the success at the end
of the day so it's all in God's hands
I've never tried to lie I've never tried
to hurt innocent people
but I have had a big footprint and I
have stepped on people and I'm sorry for
that uh but the past is the past and I
you know I don't even really look back
at the past uh uh I mean I studied the
past understanding the future but
I'm just trying to improve myself now
and just trying to get as humble as
possible and just really praying that we
don't have a nuclear war and that we can
just have a future I really I mean used
to I wanted to be number one and I would
get a little jealous of other people
that were really successful uh but the
best thing in my life has been really
realizing it's the human Continuum and
that we're all basically on the same
journey together and other people's
success against tyranny is My Success so
I'm the happiest I've ever been uh and
uh and I just all the persecution's been
wonderful uh it's really taught me a lot
and uh and it's helped me be a better
person so I I want to thank my enemies
for everything they've done to me and I
want to encourage them not to be
destroyed by their master that will
destroy them and I want to have a future
with them on a planet we can all live on
and so I want to tell my enemies I love
you and I care about you and Jesus loves
you and you just need to ask Jesus to
come into your heart and God will set
you on the right path and forgive you
and that's really the answer and I'm
just really encourage them to find God
because let me tell you God and the
devil are real you better get that
straight yep where did this come from
man how long did it take this it's
Epiphany phase this is I like what
you're basically saying is like you've
been humbled right you were at the top
of the podium and then boom you've been
brought down everything that's happened
to you is it is it Pastor Rodney is it
you're reading the Bible well you're
you're praying for your enemies you well
I've always been I mean I've always been
a Christian but then I kind of slip out
of here and turn into the Tasmanian
devil uh I mean literally it's the angel
of the devil like sometimes I like
before I know
but I'm always I'm faith I'm faithful to
God I want to be here but I can jump
over the devil really easy and and so
I've always been forgiven and I've
always loved other people's success one
of the best things I've always been
grateful and I've never it's just that I
catch myself saying well I like that
person but still they really do great
job and you know what it's like and but
that's all of our wealth together uh and
so really enjoying the wealth of other
people's success is all our human
success Communists and socialists
authoritarians totalitarians they in
that movie The Book oil that was made in
the movie There Will Be Blood it's such
a powerful scene maybe you can pull it
up it's only like 30 seconds long where
he says
is probably the best actors ever you
know he says I have a competition in me
I don't like to see other people do well
and and I don't like other people and
he's like saying I want to like you
because you're my cousin then Larry he
learns he's faking it he looks like his
cousin he kills him but you know imagine
being alone like I said I just won't
have enough money to be left alone and
be you know completely walled off and
uh he's just not happy and and so I want
to be the opposite but you can't just be
like oh everything's yours and I'm going
to roll over to you you got to be strong
for your family strong for culture fight
tyrants to build a free market system
where we don't make people be Christian
but they want to be Christian because
that's the way they know that's going to
be successful and Empower them and and
you know have them be with God forever
and so it really is a fight good versus
evil and now people that were agnostic
very famous people
are are having spiritual experiences
some of them are having incredible
experiences with like angels and you
know the Holy Spirit and God others are
literally don't believe anything are
laying in their beds and a huge black
shadow comes in and just rips off their
shirt into huge bloody slashes across
them and then just throws them up
against the wall and then they they
start finding out well okay what do they
do and uh you know they go to a rabbi he
says put this cabal on and do this
ritual doesn't help him they finally go
get born again all of it leaves and and
you know this is this is this is
happening with sane well-known people
that were you know not atheists they
didn't hate Christians they're like ah
come on you know I don't really believe
in God and they're and they're having
the experience because if you don't have
God around you as a defense Shield you
are wide open and and the devil can't
help it and whatever this is for it's
called the devil It's gotta because if
you're doing good work but but you don't
know it's God and and have God is
literally a shield it's like being in a
submarine with screen doors you're dead
and so this stuff's going to come in if
you don't have God that's why I'm
talking about God because cause I need I
need to get closer to God I need God God
is my refuge God gets all the glory not
me Alex you're saying accepting God
accepting God Jesus is the Lord and
Savior you're saying you have to accept
Jesus uh all right well I'm Jewish uh
respect we're the O.G Christian well I'm
not I'm not putting no no no no no
that's not what I'm asking no uh we have
a lot of Muslim friends a lot of Islam
Andrew Tate just turned to uh to to a
Muslim
um abrahamic Faith hold on that's what
I'm asking I wasn't putting down you
know the rabbi this was a real story I
was telling you
this this engine cleaner worked great
this one didn't I wasn't like yeah but
your overall concept of faith and
finding God and you a lot of yours you
just said sometimes I'm the god of devil
everything's going on right there and
everything that you've uncovered with
these Satanic rituals and everything at
the um the one place up in California I
mean Grove and this you talked about the
praying to the devil and they're
sacrificing the children and everything
like this do you feel like it's just a
fight of believing in God
is that what it comes down to yeah art
types I mean for people that are you
know I'm not going to try to just push
nothing but Christianity people but
that's that's what I believe that's what
I know but absolutely the first step is
to realize there is good and evil
there's stuff we don't see there's other
dimensions and none of these globalists
are atheists they're all into the occult
they're all into weirdness they're all
super neurotic and uh or they're super
scared of God I just don't want to hear
about it like Rupert Murdoch so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]